check out this week's must-see movies  can you describe it full stop from the  beginning in annihilation scientists  explore a bizarre danger zone no we  don't need a board and we do not need  pieces in game night a friendly  competition between friends becomes far  more dangerous than anyone realizes I am  someone who wakes up in a different body  every day in every day romance becomes  very complicated for a shy teen when she  falls for someone who transforms into  another person daily see what's hot in  theaters with this week's fantasy  patient so what's your weekend ticket  going to be let us know by commenting  see you next time on weekend ticket  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]